he keeps you honest and and he just he
elevated the character in in every way
should we expect a wow line from him
will he say the word wow at one point in
the show
i keep seeing i keep seeing the memes in
the game and i
and i ask myself i'm like did i is it in
there
[Laughter]
i'm greg and i'm john we are the real
rejects
guys hi michael thank you for taking
time to talk with us today
thank you all for having me we don't
mean this in any hyperbolic way at all
we only saw the first episode of this so
far
and out of the three live-action marvel
shows this year this was easily our most
anticipated and when we say this we mean
it
this was the best pilot out of the three
live-action marvel shows we've seen so
far and
it literally gave us everything we
wanted and more so you just keep kicking
ass that's what you do
thank you guys at the end of the
interview that's the end thank you
michael just wanted to compliment you
great thank you guys so much i i really
appreciate that
of course of course uh johnny you want
to ask the first question absolutely so
so you know i mean obviously we've seen
a
version of loki play out from the first
thor through infinity
war do you think that your version of
loki this version of the character will
be the definitive one and do you
even want that mantle on your shoulders
that's an that's a good question i mean
i i think
time will tell truly you know there
there was the version of loki that
that went through that arc all the way
up to infinity war
he did perhaps have some sort of quasi
redemption
right but but here we are picking up
with loki
at what i would say is his most arch he
just got his ass handed to him by the
avengers he's
he's desperate he's a little humiliated
and we're going to send him on a totally
different journey
that was it was very important to me
that we told a new story with loki and
we didn't just do something that the
fans had seen before and that that was
something very important to tom and kate
as well
so does this guy become the definitive
version
can there be a definitive version of
loki maybe
that's the question with that in mind
one thing we
we really loved about the especially
from the first episode was like the
deconstruction the the psychological
sort of like
existential exploration of loki just as
a person in the first episode being the
writer
like what is it about his identity that
you specifically wanted to bring to the
table or to explore us to not just
repeat the same type of character arc
like you were just talking about
yeah i think it was because i i knew
look we're doing tv now
and and here we are we're taking a
blockbuster super villain
and we're gonna have six episodes with
this guy which means
we can live in these quieter moments
and actually go in depth in the
character in a way that maybe you can't
in a two and a half hour movie and that
so that means more
introspection more self-reflection
and everything and that was my goal with
it
i think from the first episode like
that's what
kind of reminds me like that jurassic
park scene when they're debating about
should they do the ethics of the
dinosaur stuff like the scenes with
owen wilson and uh and tom heddleson
were just fantastically written
and uh speaking of owen wilson i mean
transition perfectly cast
as mobius uh did you have his voice in
your head at all like what at what stage
were you writing
for him versus just writing this
character and uh did owen wilson
you know engage with you in that process
at all yeah i mean no i
i was i was writing mobius initially
without anybody in mind
think thinking kind of like a tom hanks
kind of cure i love that
not thinking about casting tom hanks but
the sort of
character that that tom hanks would have
would have played back in the day
and that was just inspired casting you
know from kate
our directors uh kevin wright our
creative producer and seraphin our
casting director they brought owen on
relatively close to the start of
production
and then i got to spend time with owen
talking about the character
going through the scripts and everything
owen is a great
writer in his own right so if there was
anything happen asked in the script he
would you know
best believe he was going to call it out
which is good you know he keeps you
honest and he just
he elevated the character in in every
way
should we expect a wow line from him
will he say the word wow at one point in
the show
i keep seeing i keep seeing the memes
and i ask myself i'm like did i
is it in there
look in in the same way that people are
are looking for big cameos
maybe that's that could be the most
anticipated moment of the whole show
probably yeah yeah sure i guess i'll
i'll under with this i'm sure you've
been asked about this quite a bit but
you are also a writer on doctor strange
too did it help
having like that extra insight into the
future of the
the mcu multiverse and how did you were
able to maintain your focus on loki
despite working
it sounds like extensively on both
projects
yeah i mean of of course with with the
mcu
the more projects you you work on and
the more you've done
uh the easier your life is because you
just understand
the world and the stories being told
better
you know my focus was very much on loki
and it's like it wasn't until
the the writing and that was really felt
like it was in a good place that
things picked up on dr strange
so you know you always just want each
project to be great
individually on its own and then they
kind of naturally feed into one another
that makes sense well on all sincerity
we love the hell out of this this is
amazing really excited to continue
and we all and yes and i'm sure many
people have paid you this compliment
already but we've seen all the rick and
morty were big rick and morty fans too
so like this this show just is like this
is us this is our show right here this
is the marvel show we wanted hopefully
we keep it going over the next few
absolutely believe so thank you so much
for your time i know you got a busy
schedule thank you so much for talking
with us
have a good day take care